hello everybody and welcome to a video
that i've debated about making for a
while now when i made my last video on
uh beginner level puzzles i claimed that
it was the end of the puzzle solving
series but i've gotten a lot of requests
to do a video where i essentially solve
grand master level puzzles where i show
everybody what puzzles at my level
actually look like
and um i've decided to listen and so
this in this video i'll be solving uh
grant what i believe to be approximately
grand master level puzzles or master
level puzzles
um why did i hesitate before making this
video well there are sort of two very
specific logistical concerns that i'm
going to put out on the table and warn
you about
the first is that
some of these exercises and as you can
see i've set the range to be 2750 to
3100 which i think is approximately
accurate uh some of these might be
easier some of these might be harder but
uh you know don't nitpick
uh but with some of the harder exercises
they require a tremendous amount of
visualization and sometimes long five
six move variations and i was worried
that
um it might be hard for for some people
to follow and benefit from the videos
which of course is the ultimate goal so
what i've done to try to remedy that
i've opened up chess base and if we get
a puzzle that i feel like requires a lot
of visualization i am going to reproduce
the position on chest space so that we
can actually move the pieces and i can
walk you through
my my thinking while moving the pieces
and i'm technically that would not be
something i normally do
i normally try to visualize everything
but that's a judgment call that i might
make with some of the exercises and
the second thing that i want everybody
to understand is that i might get some
of these exercises wrong
and you know when i solve on this level
my accuracy is generally i'd say roughly
80 to 90 percent so it's pretty high but
of course i do come across puzzles that
uh that stump me and sometimes i make
dumb mistakes so
um i feel like there's this
misconception that grandmasters hold the
keys to the kingdom and you know all
these exercises come easy to me and i'm
not sure if this will make you happy or
sad but that's totally untrue
and what i've been doing in the previous
videos you know the process that i've
been going through is not just me
dumbing it down that's what i actually
do when i solve exercises at this level
as you're going to see
um it's just that you know some of the
observations that you have to make some
of the lines you have to calculate are
more complicated
so i absolutely there's a possibility
that i'll get stumped or that i'll have
to spend some time thinking in silence
or that i'll get a problem wrong and
i'm not ashamed of that that's just
something that happens i want to give
you the genuine experience i'm not going
to edit anything out
um and you know again i hope that that
gives you a more realistic take on how
puzzle solving looks at my level which
is basically exactly the same as puzzle
solving on any level
uh so with that with that behind us
let's let's jump in and see what we can
see what we're gonna get
okay um
isn't this just a mate in one
okay this is a really funny
i i think i set the range to be 27.50
rook f2 is just mate
28.87 okay if if these puzzles if these
are grandmaster level puzzles then i
guess you all can become a grandmaster i
suppose they they thought the difficulty
was that black had a a fork on g5 but i
didn't even see that fork i mean this is
a classic arabian mate that's hilarious
okay if we get any more of this i i'm
going to to set the range even higher um
wow that might just be a misrated puzzle
or something like that
anyways great start guys all right
okay so this seems like a more
uh suitable one
all right so it's black to play
we're we're down we're down a piece
we're down a piece white's up a night
okay but
clearly with the first thing i see is
that we have doubled rooks here on the
set on the c file and we can take the
pawn on c2 that seems to be a very
logical way to begin but let's try to to
find the follow-up right because
you know you don't just want to guess
you want to limit the guessing that you
do you want to always find the follow-up
even when the first move seems obvious
uh so rook takes c2 check the king is
going to step aside
uh 2b1
okay and then we need to find a
follow-up there
um well we can't really take the bishop
there the queen defends the bishop the
queen also defends the knight so white's
queen is a little bit overloaded
that's one thing that i
that i'm noticing here
so what about rook takes c2 king b1
maybe we can just play it simple and
take the pawn on f5 of the queen hitting
the knight and if the knight moves away
then the queen has a direct line against
white's king so we're going to have some
sort of a discovery possibly checkmate
are there any issues with that approach
so rook takes c2 king b1
queen takes f5
okay so the question is if white can't
move the knight can white defend the
knight
well yes white can defend the knight
there's this annoying move bishop d3
and um
the problem there is that that bishop
hits the rook and it defends the knight
so
we might have to move the rook back and
then we're still down a piece so that
doesn't seem
entirely suitable
okay so if rook takes c2 doesn't work
let's go back to the initial position
and you know marinate on this for a
second i need i need a moment here just
to think about
what to do in the initial position
i'm going to take maybe 30 seconds or so
just to think about this and then i'll
share my my observations
i found that sipping coffee is a good
way to get the creative juices flowing
okay so there there there
taxi to king moves
queen a4 queen a4
oh we can also go queen a4 here
i'm thinking about this move but then
the knight drops back to c3 again it
seems like white
is able to defend
okay so let's go back to rook take c2
rook take c2
king b1 let's look more carefully in
that position can i find anything there
boom boom queen takes f5 bishop d3
all right
i guess we could
play something like rex c4 there that
doesn't smell like the solution though
okay well
i think we're going to go for a rook
takes c2
and then
we are going to think after king b1 is
played sometimes getting the position a
little bit closer can can actually do
wonders for your visualization there's
something there that i'm missing the
first move is correct
so there was something here that i am
missing
what could it be now we can take the
knight okay we can take the knight we
have to check the captures that's what
you always have to do but then the queen
takes the bishop and what have we gained
from the trade i don't see anything
okay we can also take the bishop
oh we can take the bishop queen takes c2
and then we can play queen takes f5 and
try to go after the knight
white's probably going to defend the
night with rook g to e1
and then we can pick the night off with
d5 so that's an option what's going to
happen at the end of that after we win
the night we're going to have we're
going to be down in exchange
but we are going to have three pawns for
it that again
the metric for
solving these exercises is higher than
that black might be slightly better
there i don't think that's the solution
i have an idea
so i was looking at this night and
thinking well what other ways could we
attack the knight and i came up with i
think what could be a very promising
move
and that's what if we just go completely
the other direction we go queen a4
we go queen a4
now how does that actually help it hits
the knight from a different side
it could seem that the knight just moves
back to c3 right because we're not
threatening a discovery anymore but then
we play rook takes c3
and white cannot take back with the pawn
because he gets mated our queen on a4
captures on a2 so i feel like coming at
the black white king from this side
is going to offer more attacking chances
than
what we just tried there so let's let's
try queen a4 i think that might be it
that's it
okay so f takes g6
um
and all right so here i think we have
forced mate and this is just a pattern
recognition thing you might be tempted
by taking the knight but one of the
things you see at this higher level is
uh these exercises have a lot of false
false positive moves and a lot of
tempting pieces that are lying by the
side of the road you can't lose track of
the goal see the problem with taking the
knight here
is that white's going to take on f7 it's
going to be a double check and look at
black's king it's going to be all
exposed
let's say queen takes e4 f2 g takes f7
king f7 and rook f1 check that seems
really messy black's king gets tossed
around the whole board i don't think
that's a good way to go plus i think i
see force mate we can play rook takes b2
check and i think probably you see that
in all the time i've spent blabbering
king takes rook is forced the other rook
comes into c2 the king has to go back to
b1 and then the queen checkmates on a2
so rook takes b2 sort of clearing the
defense
boom boom
and that was the 3000 rated puzzle the
hard part here was queen a4 that was not
an easy move to come up with
uh just because you're my eyes were
constantly drawn to the f5 font i had
this instinct to capture it but after
bishop d3 there was no follow-up so i
had to find other ways of accomplishing
the same idea and so i came up with uh
the concept of physically positioning
the queen closer to where the attack is
and that did the trick
all right next oh this one's going to be
juicy i can already smell that because
white is down a queen
okay down a queen
we have a rook black's king is an
ungodly spot so my guess is this gonna
this is gonna be uh something where we
try to checkmate use the limited
resources at our disposal to check me
the black king
probably with a rook somewhere on the b
file
all right so that's probably to be the
target position i also see that white
black's queen at least for the time
being is completely
you know excommunicated from the game so
we actually have time not every move
needs to be a check how do i know that
well i can see that black is not
threatening anything and black's king is
not getting out anytime soon in order to
to threaten something the queen will
have to move to h4 then it's gonna
threaten checkmate on e1 so we have at
most one tempo we have one move that's
not a check so one thing we could try to
do is set
for example an unstoppable threat
and uh let's think about
specific moves i think we know what we
want to try to do we want to try to get
this rook
somewhere on this b flat we also have
this f pawn which we can push at some
point maybe to distract the bishop maybe
the bishop will be blocking the rook
somehow
how do we put that all together well
also i wouldn't rule out the possibility
that our bishop
participates in the checkmating
procedure
okay so let's think
the first idea that i have just to get a
feel for the position if we go rook up
to e8
well there's a problem that doesn't do
anything because the b8 square is
protected by the bishop black is gonna
go queen h4
the rook actually does not have any
direct way to get to one of these three
squares because rookie seven is going to
be captured okay so what if we promote i
have an idea what if we promote
and then if the bishop takes the queen
okay
then we're gonna go rook up to e6 and i
don't think black's gonna have a way to
stop rook b6
but i see an issue with that logic if we
promote to a queen amazingly black does
not have to take that queen right that
queen from f8 if you look at it very
carefully
is not threatening to go to b8 because
that square is protected i'm afraid that
black can go queen h4 and despite white
having a new queen we're still not going
to be able to stop black's queen from
getting to e1
so
that's a little bit worrisome
and so that leads me to another idea
maybe
i mean i saw in my mind's eye quickly i
saw another mating
mating position possible mating position
here's what i saw
let's say hypothetically that this
bishop from f3
is able to get to c6 and then capture
the pawn on a4
the king will have to capture and then r
king slides over to a2 this is a pretty
common mating pattern using the king to
push the pawn to b3
and that's going to keep black skin and
mating that
so if we can get our bishop to c6
quickly it's going to be threatening
bishop takes a4
well how can we do that we'll have to
move our rook
we can't just move it anywhere we have
to move it to a square where black has
to respond to the threat so what if we
move it to e7
what if we move it to e7 move it to e7
well black will have to take it right
because we're threatening rook b7 then
we go bishop c6
um one red flag is that i'm not sure how
this pawn is involved yet but maybe it's
not rookie 7 bishop takes c7 bishop c6
and i have a crazy claim for you i don't
think black can stop
despite having the move i don't think
black can stop us from capturing on a4
and then playing king a2 oh he can oh
man so rookie 7 bishop takes c7 bishop
c6 right
black can try the old move queen h4 but
that doesn't help anymore we play bishop
takes a4 uh bishop takes a4 king takes
a4 king a2
and then we're threatening pawn b3
checkmate and even if the queen slides
into f2
notice that we have this pawn on e2
blocking the queen so it's not a pin we
can push our b pawn now here's the issue
rookie 7 takes bishop c6 the black queen
goes back to h8
and after bishop takes a4 king takes a4
king a2
we go queen b8
and unfortunately the queen covers the
b3 square
okay so we need to put you know it's
like the bad guys are heading to
uh are heading to our house we need to
slay a tree the tree has to be
uh has to be covering the road do we
have such a tree at our disposal what we
do we have the f-pawn right what if we
push it at the right moment at the right
moment and force the bishop
to take that pawn
and then black screen is not going to be
able to get to b8 anymore now we already
know that f8 queen here does not do the
trick because black is not going to
respond but what if we do it second we
play rookie 7 black has to respond to
that then we promote to a queen
now already at this point the queen is
threatening to go to b8 because black's
bishop is no longer covering that square
it's now on e7 it's captured a rook
there okay so rookie 7 bishop takes c7
f8 equals queen
black has to take that queen then we go
bishop c6
and if black goes queen h8 the queen is
going to meet that tree at the center of
the road the road's closed off it can't
come to b8 we play bishop takes a4 king
takes a4 king a2 if that's the solution
that is one stunning exercise
so just to repeat one more time we go
rookie seven to distract the bishop and
to open up our bishop then we go f8
equals queen forcing the bishop back to
f8 so that it blocks this passageway
that the queen could take then we go
bishop c6 and on pre-move we play bishop
takes a4 then king a2 and b3 checkmate
i'm pretty confident that that's the
solution yep now we can't forget about
this move yep bishop c6 they're trying
queen h4 as you can see black is just
one tempo behind boom
boom and if you had trouble visualizing
maybe now uh you'll have an easier job
seeing what what the fuss is all about
because um pawn d3 is checkmate and it's
unstoppable the king cannot evacuate to
b5 there's a pawn there
okay so queen let's finish it off b3
and that's another 3 000 rated exercise
i would say maybe on par with the last
one but a different kind of hard that's
another thing that you see at this level
is you see different kinds of heart
exercises the previous one forced us to
find a quiet move this one is a series
of boom boom boom sacrifices we have to
find the mating concept which is really
hard to spot you know this bishop c6
bishop takes a4 idea
hard but not impossible next next
position
okay
so
what's going on here clearly white has a
pretty monumental
attack against black's king the king is
in the center i'm already seeing a bunch
of checks on this diagonal that are
possible i'm also seeing that after
bishop c6
the king has to go up to e7 and this
other bishop could come into a3 that
looks like checkmate but it's actually
not the knight could cover on d6
okay so first idea i see what if we take
the knight to try to go bishop c6 and
bishop a3 that's not gonna cut it
because then black's gonna take back
with a pawn
and the c6 square is all of a sudden
going to be protected by the queen
those kinds of things rarely work when
you sack your queen to
you know to make some flimsy sequence
work the position is going to change you
know it's like the butterfly effect
uh something's going to change and then
the entire concept is not going to work
so
let's go back to the initial move bishop
c6 check that seems like a good place to
start king up to e7
okay so i think i've spotted a mate um
one idea that i came up with is to
capture this rook with a queen
and the idea is to lure the king back to
d8 and then advance the rook up to b8
and that's sort of a rook and bishop
kind of construction that's familiar to
me that forces the king back to e7
but then there's a problem so
let's go through that again bishop c6
king e7 queen takes the eight and again
if you have a board nearby i won't set
up these positions on chess base uh but
you can absolutely set this up on a
board nearby and follow along bishop c6
king e7 queen takes king takes then this
rook slides up to b8 the king escapes
the e7 and initially i thought that rook
e8 was checkmate
but it's not the king can evacuate to d6
do we have at our disposal a means of
covering that d6 square we do remember
that early on i mentioned the idea of
bishop a3 so what if we throw that move
at exactly the moment when the king goes
up to e7
the knight will have to cover and then
rookie 8 is actually checkmate because
the knight i know that's a lot of arrows
but the knight is going to be pinned by
the bishop on a3 and the bishop from c6
is going to defend the rook from the
king's capture
so once again bishop c6 king e7 we take
the rook we go rook b8 check the king
goes back to e7 then we throw in bishop
a3 forcing the knight to deprive the
king of its last escape square the queen
on f6 stops the king from coming to f6
then rookie it is me
not too difficult if you are well
acquainted with with mating patterns
uh but nonetheless that's a pretty long
variation boom boom checkmate 2900 that
sounds about right
yeah that first one was a false positive
okay so here we have another i guess
what chess.com basically claims is that
these these puzzles that have made in
one are made in two
it's so tempting to make another move
that they believe that it obscures the
obviousness of the mate but i don't
really agree with that here i think it's
just a maiden two we start with bishop
g3 check that's the first move that
comes to mind and after king d2 that
knight on g5 is hanging but if you just
sort of look at the whole board if you
force yourself to look at all areas of
the board you'll immediately see that
the correct move is queen takes d4
checkmate
um and and you have to train yourself to
do that when there's a hanging piece or
there's a hanging pawn you can't limit
your search to that square or that piece
you have to look at the whole board you
have to put things in context because
often you'll have a much better way of
attacking
okay that was easy enough
we can definitely do
a couple more one or two more
all right this one seems pretty juicy
all right
so let's unpack this well white's down a
piece first of all first thing i see
whites down a minor
um but the black king is clearly in
danger
so i see for example we have knight h7
check we have 96 check in fact 96 check
wins black's queen and i think that's a
move a lot of people would go for
but what's the problem with that move
again it's all about not missing the
forest for the trees after bishop takes
c6 rook takes d8 rook takes d8 count how
many pieces black has for that queen
black is a rook and two minor pieces for
the queen that's more than enough
material that's not gonna do
right that's a very very common mistake
when solving these exercises is to go
for the line that wins the queen without
realizing that
you know you're giving up a kingdom and
a horse
uh in return for that miserable
queen
so i say we we scratch 96 and we go for
the other check not h7 let's look at
that move
i think black has to take the pawn on f7
king e7 just seems unthinkable i think
the hard part of this exercise is going
to be to find a follow up to knight h7
king takes f7 because we have a bunch of
different tempting checks there we have
rook f1
we have queen up to d5 we have rook f2
and you know teasing out which of those
is the most promising is going to be a
pretty monumental task but let's get to
it knight h7 king takes f7
first i'm going to take 30 seconds or so
just in silence to get my bearings
so there there there
i have a pretty good sense of what i
think it is but
i just want to verify that
yeah that looks like it
one
g8 or takes d7
okay
so i'll share my thoughts knight h7 king
takes f7
the first thing i saw was this rook f1
check that seems very natural right just
bringing another piece in the attack the
king is probably gonna go back to g8 i
don't see any other good squares
then if you look carefully you'll see
that the queen x-rays the king
okay for this one i actually think i'm
going to set this up in chess space
and then i'm going to switch scenes so
this is going to take me a second again
i
will specifically not edit this out i
want to show you what the process looks
like this is not something i would
normally do
but um there's a lot of intricacies here
and i want to make sure that
i'm explaining them clearly
so this will just take me a hot second
to set up
pawn here got to make sure i'm not
missing
any pawns or else we'll have have a mess
okay there we go
and let's see if i can
seamlessly switch scenes yes okay this
works
for me to get something technological to
work is like a monumental achievement
we have the board
that white part on top is generally
where the the names of the players go
but here we don't know who's playing so
it's left blank
all right so knight h7
king takes f7
and now i'm thinking about rook f1 why
am i saying that the king has to go back
to g because i'm intuitively ruling out
any king move along the e file i feel
like if the king goes back to e8 we're
gonna have checkmate here it might be in
two moves it might be in three but it's
no question that a king on e6 is going
to be checkmated by
the 800 pieces we have surrounding and
not even knight fa which i mouse lift is
a good move
that says a lot so king g8 is forced now
i saw that the queen is x-raying the
pawn and so the move knight f6 came to
mind
but again this is another case of tunnel
vision because okay if queen takes f6
then rook takes f6 and one could argue
the plaque does not have enough for the
queen black has only two miners with the
queen so the king has to move
and then we can take this bishop with
our rook
but this creates a fork we're forking
the queen and the maid threat but the
queen could slide over to f8 very
annoying move
and i don't see a follow-up we have
maybe a discovery with a knight but look
at our king our king is also very weak
the queen is threatening to come to b4 i
don't like it
so rather than abandoning the whole line
i go back to the last moment at which i
had a choice
which is an advice that i've shared
before and that would be this moment do
we have to go knight f6 but when you
have
one of these sequences like knight f6
and rook takes d7 that's two moves
um you should always check what happens
if you switch up the move order so what
if we start with rook takes d7 see the
point here is that the queen doesn't
have f8 anymore that square is now
covered
black could throw in rook before check
which was concerning at first but i
think the king just hides on a1
and that's it black is out of checks
black has to take the the rook and now
we go knight f6 and knight takes d7 and
we have
we have a queen for a rook and three
pawns which is not
which is borderline convincing but also
i would say that black's king is really
weak here so we're threatening rookhop
seven and rook two and this is
completely winning i think there's no
doubt about that so i would say that
that is the likeliest solution
i didn't really check for other options
i mean maybe a move like queen d5 is
interesting and i feel like this is
really messy black has bishop b6 and
king e7 black as all these options king
g6 has to be considered rook f1 is by
far the most forcing move
and those are the moves that you should
start with even at these highest level
problems let's go back to
um let's go back to the uh the other
scene
and just give me a second here
all right there we go
and let's attempt the solution knight h7
rook f1 rook d7 and that is correct
knight takes d6 see that was 29 42 but i
would say that was perhaps our hardest
exercise
and i think that's a good exercise to to
stop on i could do more and i think that
i will definitely do subsequent videos i
think this went pretty well i think i'll
do subsequent videos where i solve more
of these exercises
uh but i think you get the point
hopefully and i also hope that you
enjoyed enjoy these puzzles as you can
see i was pretty close to getting some
of them wrong
um some of them involved a little bit of
guesswork
i was stumped on on the second one
uh but but this is what it looks like
i'm still making observations i'm still
doing the same calculation it's just
that as i said before the
level of observations that you have to
make that the stuff that you have to
look for that could that gets a lot more
complicated at this level
but it doesn't fundamentally change and
so you can absolutely go on chess.com
and attempt this level of exercise even
if you're a beginner or an intermediate
player and hopefully you'll be able to
see that you can solve some of them
correctly and those of you those that
you can't you can always learn from and
try to understand what observations you
fail to make that kind of stuff is
really helpful even if a little bit
dejecting at times well thank you for
watching i hope you enjoyed the video
and i'll definitely be making more of
these in the near future i'll see you in
the next video bye